gianni bismarck a tor marancia nessuno
ha mai fatto un fischio aumentato del
culo
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una nuova
puntata di vita buttata oggi mi farò un
tè in compagnia di gianni bismarck vamos
mamma mia grazie mille per essere
l'unica al centro dello allora io so che
stai facendo un botto di cose sei in
tour niente uscito il nuovo disco dai
ragazzi senti come sta andando sarà bene
stanno bene sono contento
la tournée anche dell'estate giu
strutture nuovo come stanno un po chiude
le doti e come una molto presto faremo
uscire
ragazzi in link qua sotto cliccate e
trovare tutti quanti biglietti allora
senti io ti offro naturalmente qui è
tutto analcolico che sia chiaro che in
toni chiaro il gin tonic però trovato
virgin coma occhi chiusi
questo calcio c'è storia vaio questa
apre su questo a bordo no ai mesi a buy
di raso
ma sto pensando alla destra personal ora
la rivincita
ma grande sceglierò chi può tutto
sceglierà nel cocktail di sbagliarci ma
sono previsto questo gesto sono sereno
una zolletta c'è la nostra
cioè lo
perdiamo
uscite queste moto scivola sta cosa
stavo strappo di analcoliche stivale
acqua
nuova puntata vita buttata vamos
[Musica]
tu sarò mazza perfetta che potevo sapere
allora ecco che nessuno ha mai fatto un
fischio mente io c'è una domanda farti
ma perché tutta la gestualità esiste un
codice
l'offerta uguale resterò sempre le
stesse cioè nel senso questo basta che
poi sono capito ci sta un amico di
gianmarco che appena ha saputo che te
vieni qua impazzito da un passito tipo
coperto come ricordo un sacco e quindi
magari se vedemo
giocatore toccato agli acidi volevo mi
ha mandato una lista di cose sembra un
profiler di tipo dei criminali capito
gianni bismarck a tor marancia parte
così roma sud ed è cresciuto fra tor
marancia e garbatella fin da giovane ha
giocato a pallone militando anche nella
romulea oppure dove conosce toni f toni
a follina dominata del territorio
baciarmi st le foto di mio padre tonino
così piccoletto non sono l'idea è tifoso
sfegatato giallorosso lavoro in cucina
per vari anni in trattoria penso si
chiama tiziano in realtà inizia a fare
musica spinto da sic duke sale grande e
pubblica il primo mixtape nel 2015
potesse morire cosa avevo anch'io che
davvero c'è un link scotti pippen poi
importantissimo non fuma erba ma solo
per fumo bono sapesse giocatori o
appassionato di stornelli romani quando
sta st miccoli ostiniamo ragazzo che è
adorabile ho capito chi è lei definito
il poeta dei trastevere il giorno in cui
ho conosciuto mia moglie e la futura
madre dei miei figli
le ho vomitato sulle scarpe buona
giornata
buono io ho conosciuto uno quando ha
conosciuto suo marito il primo giorno io
comitato però poi si sono sposati lei è
stato quello il trucco
magari già visto lungo una mia amica
un'altra volta si è dimenticata era così
ubriaco che si è dimenticata che la
tavoletta era chiusa cioè necessito da
sopraffatto abertis alzata e poi ha
visto che ha fatto un macello disco
d'oro e un muso strappato scusa ha
strappato tutto utilizzi tipo per tutto
è 80 per cento delle cose sto strappato
di esprimeva non c'è lo strappo di fini
è smontato o sabato
mamma che voglio fare è dopo quanto
tempo mediamente secondo voi si
esaurisce la trazione
ma di una relazione del primo periodo
danno e ho scritto un pezzo che ha
lasciato la donna e parlavo questa cosa
che l'amore è bello solo il primo anno
costa ragazze sono stato tre anni forse
pure qualcosa di più i tg che era già
con un lavoro una bella parte di palazzo
ma chi ha lasciato chi può lascia da io
posso ritornato le ater punto è rimasto
del v8 è capitato a che fare con una
ragazza ha detto secondo me è scappato
un po scorrettamente
[Musica]
astrali quando e quando due cose un p e
bar bagno svaghi dice una cosa non
sbaglia più oscure giocatore bravo o se
no la cosa peggiore che può succedere
quando da trattiene può discutere john
forza della successo
roma successo terminerò io so
esattamente di cosa stai parlando nota
però mi ricordo di aver fatto una mossa
tu sei a letto giri pancia giu nel
frattempo che quella persona non vede
perché sta un pochino così in mezzo
cuscini un look e allegria alzi le
coperte e la cicoria culo lanci nel
frattempo ansimando nell'orecchio in
maniera erotica ma solamente per coprire
l'udito
richiudi giù quel giorno mi è successo
per prestava ad un miglio
un'altra ragazza o prova fasta tecnica
che volevo iniziato ci pensa male
altrimenti ci stanno aveva detto magari
ma faccio un presente st
dormirete lì
avrei saltato che ho fatto il nuovo
fatto intestare a berlino e ho fatto
cioè dal giorno dopo era gravissimo però
dedicato vissuta male abu preso male che
sto dice qui state sarà sentita per
evitare di doverci trovare a secco in
altro per me è un onore a farti
divertire su sta cosa mai
state infatti fa idea
avevate prima la riempì non te ne sei
accorto ma ripido vero cuore quello
analcolico
allora secondo detto er marancia quando
vede tempino così che ti dice confucio
si stavano si tappi su una messa come
vedete ho detto
lascia cielo dai non aveva assunto
[Musica]
una una sigla ringrazio la casa il primo
il primo mio ospite che fa che fa
cocktail
[Musica]
c'era 31 mario
benvenuti a connessione mentale un gioco
che noi non abbiamo assolutamente
plagiato copiato da altri giochi
presenti in altri shop la villa è
benvenuta grazie qui che hanno veramente
ogni invito a qui per me è un grande
grazie all'atletismo fine sarà il nostro
giudice quando la linea scacciare a
questo pulsante noi che giocheremo
insieme otterremo un punto avremo dei
cartoncini io dovrò scegliere tra questi
cartoncini una domanda da fare nel
frattempo di dover scegliere a caso una
risposta se quando io leggerò la domanda
tu avere una risposta che match a noi
otterremo un punto perché avremmo creato
una confessione mentale tutto questo
però lo faremo con delle cuffie
sparandoci bravi ragazzi nelle orecchie
in modo da non avere la possibilità
minima di barare nonio mamma papà come
nascono i bambini
palle ed è
mamma ma va come nascono i bambini ha
iscritto il cielo su di uno dei palli
cosa mi crea flatulenze incontrollabili
clitoride
il prossimo romanzo di jay che rowling
harry potter alle
riservato qualche senso il prossimo
romanzo di jk rowling harry potter e
allergia preservativo
il mio primo pensiero al mattino a dare
il 110 per cento no non ci siamo è stato
folle va beh non è vero è un mai
domo so chi ha paura la felicità è avere
i primi pubblici tra i denti
abbiamo preso sono tutti tranne il
notaio proprio fermerà per favore la
frase completa la felicità è
assurdo avere per i pubblici credenti
ragazzi siamo io non vado più
ok ma dov'è adesso con le risposte ai
suoi il domenicale di cavalli cosa ho
portato dal messico nonna
è ormai di luce che
cosa ho portato dal messico nord
la mattina adoro l'odore di fino alla
guida a praia ho sentito
rocco siffredi nel tempo libero
colleziona anziani uomini giapponesi
benissimo cosa piace a silvio berlusconi
un panino col prosciutto è mai dico mai
trinca cosa avere a silvio berlusconi un
panino col prosciutto pazzesca mazza
qual è la nuova dieta del momento la mia
vita sessuale
e mailing cosa usano gli insegnanti per
ispirare al successo i ragazzi a
sorpresa
io non so quanti punti abbiamo fatto ma
comunque complimenti miei suoi a dire
questo complimenti
ma tu sei pazzo
quante volte in cui mamma dovuto pulire
lievitante della nike
uomo e un aria
di me c'è l'uomo
presenta
uomo strano fra l'altro che mi confessa
di avere una zona di inferiorità nei
confronti del padre e io da ingenuo
sognatrice e romantica pensa alle cose
più banali questione economica
altezza bellezza donne avute e invece no
il suo problema con il padre era appunto
il bene del padre tant'è vero che
benpensano esamina fototipo voluto che
il padre e io e scioccata e poi mostra
anche la sua ovviamente di foto
giustamente le file con fronte per
essere confortato questo appuntamento
l'abbia preso da amare
ma come si arriva al 3 appuntamento a
parlare di una cosa di massa male ma
soprattutto perché i tuoi un santino di
tuo padre nudo che porti in giro e fra i
ritiri oppure te sempre da ballo vorrei
di spesa è giusto la lunghezza
no è come si usa alcun quadrati posso
dire è come si usa però cioè quello
no non basta parlare di valore del culo
a camera
quindi
presentano il padre
volevo farmi la domanda dov'è il posto
più strano dove avete fatto d'amore un
vaso in salute
ragazza alla parte non presupposto che
io apprezzo particolarmente le domande
aperte generiche così che arrivano io
c'ero l'ho fatto dove non si dovrebbe
fare un estate era così tanto il teasing
che c'era fra me e quest'altro tipo io
stavo uno di famiglia lui stava con
tutti i suoi nemici in vacanza quindi
non è che c'era un posto dal quale
potevamo stare insieme vado a trovarlo
in albergo facciamo una partita mi sa a
burraco
ma nel frattempo strano le perché qua
tutti cosa è successo quindi che io me
ne vado non mi viene dice vabbè non ad
accompagnare la porta hai presente
l'androne delle scale dopo davanti
all'ascensore dante l'androne delle
schede con l'ascensore scusatemi c'è
veramente un comportamento inammissibile
invece in estate che stava frega una
spiaggia della festa africa ora pensate
s da solo nel giro diciamo un gruppo di
persone si è necessaria una guarda stam
sono un essere molto lo soffriamo
pensato che sta da solo
ho girato ti dico che san marino
fratelli che lotterà su casa siano esse
motto mi piace chiudere con questo così
come questa red dopo esatto con questo
aneddoto gianni stavano
io ti ringrazio davvero di essere venuto
ospite al menti esserti fatto offrire un
tè analcolico dalle grazie di cuore in
bocca al lupo cultura col nuovo disco
insomma bombazza che non ho mai detto
bombazza nella rete
grazie ragazzi anche tutti quanti a
tutti quanti voi noi ci vediamo sempre
qui non so quando ma accadrà prima o poi
ciao
[Musica]